I wouldn't advise you to try living
without it you wouldn't last very long
the fact is the services that make the
planet habitable or provided for us by
several million species all making their
own living in their own way the
difference there's actually somebody
this weekend we're saying who was now
but the Earth and Venus in many ways are
very similar they're about the same size
they each have about the same amount of
carbon in their planetary system big
difference is on earth most of the
carbon is sequestered underground and
the temperature is about 59 degrees
fahrenheit in Venus all the carbon is
out in the atmosphere and the
temperature is about 850 degrees
Fahrenheit ah primates people even
chimpanzees cannot sequester a single
ounce of carbon dioxide in their lives
the only thing that can is little
animals like the ones in the ocean
grasses plants we are absolutely
dependent every time we burn fossil fuel
the only reason most of it gets
sequestered is because living creatures
provide these services for us so we are
a part and we're by and large and not
terribly contributory part of this
incredible planetary balance wheel that
works together to make earth not Venus
so nature is incredibly important it
also happens to be incredibly beautiful
but I think we get confused it's not
important because it's beautiful
it's beautiful because it's important
the reason we like it is because in an
evolutionary sense it's what keeps us
alive we are hard-wired to respect and
love our parents because they keep us
alive and we are hard-wired to respect
and love nature because nature keeps us
alive